the slap is back after keeping quiet for
nearly a year Chris Rock finally
addressed the infamous Oscars kerfuffle
and Netflix's first ever live special
selective outrage keep watching to find
out what he said and what those on the
internet are saying about it while Will
Smith has largely apologized for his
actions Rock remains silent plotting
waiting for the perfect opportunity to
unspool his thoughts in a public manner
with Selective outrage rock ruminated on
Contemporary American politics
complained about Disneyland and
discussed this experience with raising
spoiled children of course everyone was
waiting for the Madagascar voice actors
thoughts on the slap and boy did he
deliver in the hour plus special rock
shifted the blame directly to the Bad
Boys actor and his wife Jada Pinkett
Smith saying that the Superstar Oscar
winner practiced selective outrage with
his violent actions rock made it a point
to drive home that he's not a victim and
that he took the slap with Grace
likening himself to professional boxer
Manny Pacquiao as the Applause and
cheers continue the Everybody Hates
Chris Creator expressed how he's smaller
in stature than Smith reminding viewers
around the world that Smith once played
heavywight Champion Muhammad Ali and
Michael Mann's biopic for Netflix a live
event was a boon allowing them to be the
exclusive home for Rock's unfiltered
thoughts on the slap as expected Netflix
and rock pretty much got exactly what
they wanted with the special Twitter all
riled up as a special wrapped up social
media quickly began to turn into a
dumpster fire with fans and haters
sharing their thoughts on the whole
ordeal one user tweeted someone called
the police Chris Rock just killed Will
Smith on stage another user couldn't
help but chuckle at Rock's apt use of
the word entanglements during the
special's final jaw-dropping moments
they shared that last 10 minutes was
Savage AF LOL over on Reddit the
response was mostly positive though one
redditor couldn't help but Express
disappointment that rock fumbled his
joke referencing Smith's emancipation
and concussion others were just glad to
see the spiral star finally address his
frustrations in a public forum one
commented Chris really needed to get
this Will Smith stuff off his chest
enough
Damn You Will Smith
these sentiments were echoed by another
user who praised the comedian for airing
his anger and emotions warts and all
they wrote he got to use his voice and
speak his truth and from his heart I
really thought he handled the situation
well because as Chris said he's not a
victim but he still does get to speak
the truth of how he feels some viewers
were more mixed on rock and Netflix's
live gamble one user summed it up ending
bits were funny and to be expected and
glad we got it for the first 50 minutes
were so average another user went a step
further and found the entire special to
be wrote saying I've just seen this act
done by every comedian for the past 10
years so at this point I'm sick of it
others meanwhile were definitely not
pleased by Rock's harsh words regarding
Smith's actions on Oscar Knight in a
viral tweet one commenter pointed out
that Chris Rock has no publicly known
relationship to the city of Baltimore
when the Netflix special was shot they
continued by revealing that Jada Pinkett
Smith was born and raised in Baltimore
saying y'all keep thinking it's just
jokes suggesting that rock went out of
his way to berate pink Smith one user
replied the disrespect isn't a bug it's
a feature another viewer expressed their
displeasure at the grown-up star
repeatedly calling pink at Smith an
expletive a Twitter user expressed oh my
God this is so uncomfortable Chris Rock
constantly unfunny and this will Jada
commentary is horrible similar
sentiments were echoed by another user
who described Brock's thoughts on the
slap as both quote brutal and tasteless
another commenter couldn't help but
Revel at how Rock ended up preaching his
special's title saying he definitely
demonstrated the concept of selective
outrage in that last 15 minutes Chris
Rock's selective outrage is now
available to stream on Netflix the 95th
Academy Awards meanwhile are on Sunday
March 12 2023 hopefully slap free
thank you